vous nous avez demandé s'il est vrai que
l'huile d'avocat est meilleure pour la
santé
l'huile d'avocat contient en majorité
environ 65% des gras monoinsaturés des
bons gras pour la santé cardiovasculaire
sur le plan nutritif elle se compare aux
huiles d'olive de tournesol et de
cartables en cuisine elle offre aussi
une bonne résistance à la chaleur avec
un des points de fumée les plus élevés à
plus de 270 degrés celsius même si on ne
cuisine jamais à des degrés si élevé
mais lui l'avocat
tout comme le fruit lui-même est victime
de son succès les nombreuses plantations
au mexique contribuer à la déforestation
et à la sécheresse
d'autant que cette culture exige
beaucoup d'eau vous paierez l'huile
d'avocat raffiné autour de 20 $ le litre
et en 30 et 60 dollars pour une huile
vierge biologique